so I did something stupid
so I'm just recording for you a more man
of Medan hey yeah we're bad but I wasn't
recording the game um but don't worry
we'll carry on I don't I'll tell you in
with what you missed
so basically uh we've got back on the
boat um we were talking about little
scary stories and then the fisherman
came back and there were a lot of
QuickTime events
and I hit every single one of them ww
[ __ ] and then I realized that um yeah
that I wasn't recording and I realized
that it would take me all frickin night
to get back to where I am now and to
make sure that I made the same decision
so goddamn but anyway let's carry on and
so the fishermen came back they have got
the badass independent woman would she
called again
I can't remember but they've got her
hostage everyone else is tied up in the
little room no one's dead yet and that
that is the best thing I think so we're
just gonna carry on hmm why am I like
this okay we'll just carry on apologies
but maybe I'll like actually hit some
QuickTime events for you
well while recording this time actually
recording and that would be nice so yeah
we shall see but there's something weird
about these these fishermen I thought
they were ghosts at first when they
appeared on the ship at night but then
so they took out Julius brother he
nearly got himself killed but I said
nothing
there was options to speak him I said
nothing and they let me go so that's
good well let him go so now he's back he
says Conrad oh yeah he got hit up a few
times just a few
wait
dipstick I know I've already had that
for a dipstick don't you come back
dictated what sure seems to be getting
buddy-buddy with him listening she's out
with them she's my breathing also flips
got annoyed them again for going down oh
wait no I hope he's okay
dude I want to say I want to say the
uneasy uneasy where's my mouse goodbye
everything's there
don't look for your hands once we get
Julia back maybe we could take a nice
prize okay if I can match you do the
quick seller at the school
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what do they do to her hey okay what'd
they do to you I'm fine
they didn't touch me
parents why was much money they have
ransom money
yeah we just have to wait and see they
already tie them up with anything they
want a boat surely they'd have like
proper rope to tie them up with a frame
think so and I mean I shouldn't complain
it's it's good thing
in seconds
storms eight miles away we came here on
a boat maybe we can take it yeah yeah
it's a speed boat
he's got a gun if we play our cards
right we can catch him by surprise
take him out there in his underwear uh
if you could distract them I can
women speak
dude with a gun won't even realize until
I'm long gone seven seconds I can get
out through the window we gotta break
these off first loud but then you wanna
you like a killer I'm going off to the
left do you call I'll go through the
window and get the boat you guys
distract them just stay focused and get
to the boat okay let's do it
[ __ ]
see that's one thing I'm brainy
struggling with like it's pretty
difficult to know whether the actual
Krypton events I hear medically are
it's pretty annoying
oh oh okay right yeah hobby you know
just like cool stuff
okay I can do this
[Music]
yeah I'll tell them this
[Music]
you know what
I don't
[Music]
Oh oh my god a I press upon one I know
just just do it and nobody go to these
QuickTime event
[Music]
take this use it if you have to know
[Music]
over there right here sit No
I hate people the coal seam or back to
stop film a French system in Weber okay
Olsen
come here
where is the brother is he down there
with them I can't see him which one of
you is going to tell me about this not
an Italian do
calls oh yeah
so basically what you also miss is
they found that they had a comes down
below the head coolest to go and they
were going to go scope out the next day
but I guess not the Pirates of the
fishermen I can I go do that with with
them
we don't know with them they're not
comrades they're taking it from them
a bee
you tried it's not your fault you have
me control you [ __ ]
that's me we are showing Armin just
talking you want to talk
keep the bullet down okay I'm just gonna
say this has gotta be in on this
she wants guys they travel in the same
waters oh yeah yeah they barely laid a
hand on her
I bet she told them about the Manchurian
goal their coats didn't lay honey your
girlfriend either huh
how did you come up with this [ __ ]
how [ __ ] dare you over privilege oh
yeah I really like this together this is
a trap that you set up for
put a cork in it
okay
- just happened like out of the blue and
I'm like oh my god and then he's come on
all of them
this is trash
- uh no system is good enough
you try it at me
in consequence
Milland requesting weather update
over
okay
oh my god
[Music]
they get behind for her I was like this
and just like I
until I do it I don't know I think a
first day instead
wait
okay yeah just cut it all
I did it not something
thanks I guess
anyone know about Brad see hiding
somewhere yeah right
get out get out okay keep a lid on it it
could be our ticket out
bread still Cinematheque a butter off
down there than with these psychos
oh yeah great he could get killed down
there
that's a big fool
cheapy for the whole entire fast video
he died
I haven't seen in this whole entire time
that they made my job
this is yeah this is the boat from the
beginning right
everyone still alive I have no idea how
I was doing everything wrong could they
really how because I did everything
wrong oh maybe if I made them say like
stupid things because I was saying
nothing I was just being very safe I
guess I guess kind-hearted creature I am
I'd like to offer you some forewarning
of what's to come
tempted
okay then we will turn to the bard
for inspiration the merchants of Venice
act 2 scene 7 5 2013 suit Morocco pulls
a scroll from the eye of a skull and
reads all that glisters is not gold
often have you heard that tone anyway
now that you've reached a point of
significant distress you've noticed that
you're eager to get back to your story
but here's a thing everything may not be
entirely as it seems they shouldn't have
said that
[Music]
no squealing sir miss portlets
the floor leper eat
in y'all
Oh chill at everybody that's an admirer
I have no idea
what's that what's that
go
okay now we're moving from the little
boats to a ghost I guess
[Music]
man I know that one because uh who had
is Teta med nope no thanks
[Music]
she's in jail
oh yeah
good
Thanks what does she draw her bracelet
[Music]
yeah
oh I absolutely trust your back so this
is definitely the ship from the very
beginning of the game so I did not sign
up for a trip to creep the narrative is
finally prescribed making my hair stick
up so far in front that my back
is that okay
[Music]
Merlin
hey is that the dude from the beginning
you guys tell me cuz I can't I can't
remember probably is though it would
make sense
this
anything anything interesting
okay
retire
it's a national
more memorandum okay
can you see what's in their pockets in
the bearings I should have picked up a
freaking knife Jim they probably would
have noticed
Alex didn't take the bangs death and
died
I said life is not used on the die and
do anything fun okay cool
awesome party see okay all of you into
the room
[Music]
hey it's pitch black in here give us
away
thanks to that all entirely bad does it
still have a candle
good
I love her she's so cool mmm dude even
those meatheads seem spooked you think
this ship is the mentorian gold we are
in the vicinity of those coordinates
you can't just sit around you need a
plan we're not exactly in the best
position to be making any moves second
they let their guard down we've got to
take advantage of it and get off the
ship yeah man this whole rust buckets
one tetanus shot from the bottom of the
ocean we already tried to escape didn't
exactly work out we got to get back to
the boat and find Brad what happened to
him idea they swiped our distributor cap
gonna be difficult to get anywhere
without it
what his is its shipping at cafe what
exactly is a distributor cap they'll
pretend you're talking to someone who
doesn't know anything about boats
makes the engine work no the Duke
couldn't understand in the water without
it but those guys are out panning for
Manchurian gold or whatever they think
they're gonna find in this floating
coffin gotta take advantage and look
around for a way out of here
bliss I just wanted to say that I'm
sorry I might have gotten things kind of
wrong back there
excuse me I may have kind of prematurely
come to the conclusion that maybe
you know you're working to get a side
deal with these guys or whatever but I I
mean obviously that's not true they're
being just as bad to you as they are to
us yeah allow me to translate he's
saying that he's sorry
well I mean well your apology is kinda
accepted cool cool great glad boy
friends now let's get off this boat
Cheers
oh good they're carrying on the apology
no that's nice
ah I love how Julia by the way is it's
such a trope of horror films like
they're in a really bad situation and
she's just still managed to tie up her
top she's still looking fine
look right there's anything wrong with
that fashion comes first
what we find
a bit strong comrade here
my sunglasses real real creepy
they're very tiny teeny tiny glasses
miss J Rivera hi baby doll I miss you
like crazy
oh wait wait all the places I'm gonna
die on a bonafide go ship three months
until my next leave and jumping into
your arms three months I've been on some
shore leave with the guys had a few
beers but don't worry I'm keeping
everything ready for you if you catch my
drift
nice how's work I hope the boss of yours
is leaving you alone I know you can take
care of yourself but I feel helpless
being so far away and iguana keep you
safe you I get a lot of time to think
well I'm God in the cargo holds it's
dark and spooky down there some of the
other guys have seen a figure roaming
around but I've always got you to keep
me safe too
that's okay I'll be with you soon and
get job as a mechanic and we can get
married and have two children be happily
forever together love it so much Miller
and then he died
ok let's check out this love for the
portrayed weight and what are you doing
some turning around walk walk walk Jesus
Christ is so awkward
this way wonder why this was ripped off
faster
we know saying we should fight as would
be for the lengthy question to be
they're just arguing yeah whatever
nobody wants to talk to you
fine any look I can get it open Hey
maybe we can bend it up and get out of
here no we're a bit late this would go
where are the leads it can't be worse
than here mama did you smash through
this wall
yeah sure big man on campus someone
should create a distraction this is
gonna be loud
yeah okay Conrad you do it
to be fed to try and escape and then day
with my distractions like yeah that's
fair okay I mean they told me to
distract but bar carrying seems like a
good idea right oh wait I can't I can't
can i push them today but I don't feel
like okay now I can push that table
cause if list Oh
[Music]
I also come on mommy okay again Oh sssss
Keep Calm Oh
Oh she'd be so angry
Oh
we'll be safe now No
[Music]
no [ __ ] that we have to go back for Flis
I'm the reason she got snagged no us no
heroics we got to get as far away from
you as we can be so upset if Lissa's
dead oh she's my favorite
I'm so sorry face let's say nothing Oh
due to the special security precautions
on the special edition no procedures
must be adopted by soldiers on guard
duty double guard duty on all doors and
upon all watch is no talking you're
playing of games and smoking you know I
caught no go no fun basically just don't
just don't live just just don't live
nobody's allowed in two three
3a will keep on the lookout for that
remember that guys 3a
then there's the mystery the smelly
socks they can you be cracking jokes at
the Sun you might kill flesh
that's why not me you
great
glad I put my hand in there
it's just this room is just here for
jumpscares
Oh
oh my god
did you guys [ __ ] see you though do
you guys [ __ ] see that you guys see
that did you guys see that did you guys
see that did you guys see that did you
guys see that woman do you see that lady
you see our lady she was right there I
know she's not there but she was right
there though no she's gone I just want
to know where the hell they all went
there should have been dozens as people
are born hundreds how could they all
just vanish and leave all of their stunt
line oh he won't do that all maybe we're
the ghosts he did say things about
unless I seen you guys seen the others
that's how much she's scared me on all
the kids who are here arrow
is a cargo hold three outbound Coco
Holton can't believe we just saw a lady
there was no lady
on the ship though they were all men so
why would even a spirit of a woman be
here
right cuz it was the ministry okay
oh I know she's gonna drive yourself
crazy just hope for the best
oh boy let's tie 'let's toilets another
fun
there's always creepy stuff in the
toilets dear Aeolus
I'm finally coming home this is it
darling one last trip across the Pacific
and I'll be back to you in the girls I
can't wait to see your faces tell never
Nancy to get excited they got to see
daddy real soon
and he's got gifts for y'all I'm sure
glad to be back at sea it's hotter than
and Oklahoma's summer out here on land
and there's no escape from it I've been
alright because I got your letters to
keep me going they censor him which is
probably for the best because sometimes
the other steal them to read and I don't
like them breathing our lives cute I
know it really creeps me out
he keeps telling me there's a little boy
on board it sounds like Ted I know he's
just messing with me
there ain't no way we got a stowaway our
Ops guys are far too sick now the war's
over
I bet they're evidence they are but it
shows what a place them do to a guy I
gotta go for now there's some commotion
outside that usually means I'm about
real busy for a while I'll write again
soon
he's exfoliant I kid well these little
that is people are excited to see that
wives and it's a slap to see their
whites again they're kids
okay well I guess we don't need the
bathroom
so we'll just go
you just can't believe this is happening
yeah what they live in a breath she's
still on the Duke
where did you hear that if by that you
mean that terrifying sound then no I
didn't hear it
no you did was
something moving
but there are a lot of rats here so you
know kid you could just be rats
I get so freaked out it's okay I'll
protect you
thanks bro
hello
are you talking to you but you don't
hear that
the whispering
except this old junker wheezing and
creaking oh this is nice
maybe everyone's hiding in the hole for
a big surprise party was this Oh a tiny
little tiny little stuff
interesting
I think is a rat's go that's weird
okay should we open up the lockers
now what's here
okay can I even look it oh okay there
yeah
this is a lot of reading
skipper's killed booze - this whole
goddamn trip no booze got some this
fellow who had helped upload the [ __ ]
they told me the bunch of coffins of
boards we saw the coffins at the
beginning of the game which isn't so
weird but there's some guy who made sure
the conference were all put into those
holes booze was BOM lost Perez said he
felt drunk after four cups but I said it
was something baloney it was like ditch
water just hovering the guys here
snapped I look at this box it's gonna
fire go find him and see what he saw
okay so he they're gonna go sneak to
those coffins but we know that that's
where the gas came out of as well that
starts like have all that weird stuff
happened the guy who's gonna help me get
in the hole it's been no sick minutes
isn't something else oh yeah because so
he opened up that and then got sick from
that
it's obviously making people see and
hear weird things and then just go crazy
and kill everyone still complaining
about the alcohol last night I was on to
duty and someone creeped him out he's
got spooked stop babbling about some
sergeant sergeant that went m.i.a in the
jungle recomment Jones and his cute his
crew were the ones and the boxes oh okay
I sneaked a look in Jesus there it was
just like the guy in the port had said
all laid out real nice Oh glory one over
each one if it's Jones in there they've
done it proud good old Uncle Sam
wouldn't leave
without that he'd make sure we all come
he's just going back ok that was the
last page
okay so he wrote that straight after he
looked into the coffin so I guess it
takes a while to actually make someone
feel a bit crazy it doesn't happen
straight away which makes sense because
then they would understand what it was
oh it's another one these premonitions
okay but I don't know how these help
though
I'm just not sure how I can use it to my
advantage
boy go through the door
oh he's bad fur I hate the barefoot in
that imagine busting nails
the fishermen
oh that's what you got oh so that's the
thing that makes the the boat work again
so if you can get that and then get back
to the boat we can save the nice brother
and then get out of there but I need
you can save the rabbit
you gotta be careful be careful it could
be a trap
oh yeah cuz of course they never
girl
not really such a good idea mm-hmm
not yet
okay get up
Lucille told you
you know she is that she is it's flesh
[Music]
education center party specifically bomb
thank you
she was up well for assault
don't let him out of your sight
oh yeah she's got that place on her leg
because I I grazed her knee when she
went down in there we're both on the
ground she's just too airplane
[Music]
I got this
yes
oh good god area 7c has been converted
to temporary chapel Oh career required
to be silent miss faithlyn well I mean
they were part of the army so I guess I
guess religion would help
relieves some emotional pain
but haven't seen any more ghosts yeah
but maybe I'm talking to see
just waiting for it
wait a minute we've been here before I
don't think so
I swear we've been here before Alex have
you been leading us in circles no we
haven't been able to keep moving you're
crazy
we haven't been here before whatever
members this is the kitchen some sort
mentalism as if you know your way around
a kitchen please relax just messing
around great timing
great great timing she saw something
she's like I'm not in the mood for this
weapon weapon please nice
Jesus is the kitchen after all it's
fresh what is it
what yeah be truthful she can handle
that she's a big girl
it's of yourself Oh was that good a good
thing or a bad thing yeah I think it was
good
he's relaxed and he's hello a little
time a little tiny split slither of
truthful that's the tiny tiny sitter
okay
yes they can how it's failed
according to Captain Steve Katz
here we go can I use this rusty night
can I use it can I use it
can it be my weapon can I keep it hey
easy with that we shouldn't be screwing
around right now nice blade could make a
nice severance package for my assailants
if you catch my drift
oh but we're around no we're around I
don't wanna we're at around dust that
makes us see things and that crazy
probably weapons are not the best idea
even though it seems like a logical
thing to do but I'm gonna go with my
guts and the fact that I don't like
weapons I prefer to use my words as
weapons okay
let's carry on
even though that was my initial thought
and I'm just going back on myself but
now that I've you know how do little
fingers become more logical to Hue
that's how everyone died on here right
they've started to see weird things and
then shoot each other because of it is
that another one of those yet it's
permission what wait one sec wait for me
no not the nice brother okay we'll make
sure that doesn't happen
try try and make sure somehow
where is he though wait what's he
did you hear anything
[Music]
I know he was moving in the shadows
don't be annoyed probably just rats it's
all of us don't [ __ ] laugh at me
I chose worried I look I just worry
give me a anonyme what do you want to
turn around we've seen all this before
Coolidge a we don't have a lot of
options I haven't seen this before I
don't know what you're talking about
okay no this isn't working for me one
graves caskets and crappy chapels oh you
haven't been here before not my scene
you know support it right it's gross and
it's crappy gotta get out of here -
sweet - and we got a fine Fliss yeah
he's just gonna count them what is this
I feel like I want to look at the
caskets but I know I really shouldn't so
I mean I'll have a look at them but if
it gives me the option to open them I'm
not going to hey you got a name on this
guy what are they even doing here
I don't think stuck gonna go ship for
all eternity sounds like a good plan eh
who cares where they're from or where
they're going they're dead and we're not
so let's keep it that way
that's what you think well that's not
what it seems
are you sure we did this one of them
look for a kid or something oh I don't
want to know it
let's get out of here yes maybe that's a
little baby Dracula right there and
those are his parents and they're lying
in the dirt from their native country
and they all jump on Conrad and eat off
his face at the end okay okay right
condoms
this one's shackled down there serious
locks in these caskets why would they be
chained and locked well that's one way
to end relationship
you're hilarious okay but we'll just
leave the other one
the chapel
creepy curtain look what seriously are
you trying to freak me out
is there nothing else you got just get
that but but hey I saw ice okay
what
this slowly start doing crazy I think
here's a good thing that I didn't think
help that knife
Roger that
keep looking in the corners expecting to
see another galaxy
but that was making that sound rats
my social spick-and-span [ __ ] hey this
is no time to be [ __ ] around I'm
serious I can't take it could she not
see that guy
oh she can't why am i trying to touch
him oh don't touch it why did you touch
it
I literally thought he was gonna like
trains finger in his mouth
okay this way this wait that was another
brain bug that Connie
oh she's not so brother Carney where the
[ __ ] are you
we're is Conrad must have gone on ahead
I can shout if I want no you how did he
go
we start off on great times now you're
dissing ome lady
I told her to be quiet she wouldn't
listen to me
she's rude miss me
mostly
are you taking me now why would I
okay that is going to be the end of this
episode again really really sorry about
not recording the first like 10 or 15 so
minutes of me playing this one but I
hope you're enjoying it if you want to
see more and want to see if I can stop
this from dying then do let me know in
the comments and make sure to leave a
thumbs up because that's the best way of
letting me know that you enjoy these
types of videos anyway thanks again for
watching and have a lovely evening bye